hello and welcome to this video playing
just one guitar here with black yeah i
remember that i played him recently and
really got a proper beating hmm i don't
remember what it was though what kind of
opening it was catalan it was a cat
alone yeah yeah I'd was a Catalan hmmmm
is there some some way to to avoid the
Catalan can i play something offbeat
that maybe irritates him now offbeat mom
ok let's play the Slav that took 30
seconds for that oh my goodness I came
ok that is a very sharp at the sharp
line every shape is a strong word but
it's it's reasonably sharp black ass is
usually ok here how do i get to pawn
back here Bishop c5 and guess so
are we are we still in some kind of this
theoretical position might be it's been
a while since I said that studied that
or at the end of f4 it's actually quite
annoying
no it's not it's not the end of the
world check so much for
you
while always playing like this is
completely immediately and I gets all
this preparation is that is that true
okay I'm stepping out of f5 I joined to
go King e7 rookie aid can't believe that
this is something serious for wide be
quite surprising I mean he's got more
space but is it that big a deal no he
spends time okay i'm going to e seven
droop t8 next
yeah so I was thinking I just go back
you 598
and what he's playing is like rock solid
yeah I mean s rock solid as it might be
I'm like playing and polka charms yeah
just just play two aces with position
okay I'm trying f6 and EF six g5 this
kind of thing but it's got someone light
squares he has some ponds me five is a
good move ok I'll do I'll take this
check
okay let's get the Bishop to e6 is there
anything anything that tells me that
it's not a draw not really maybe I
should have got a five preventing be for
Jack it's not it's not substantial
yeah it's very dry but we can we can
continue a little bit
ok
yeah five and just just dropping bag is
ok I think
if I go see 5 p-5 before you quickly ran
out of pawns here actually maybe c5 and
King e5 is this an interesting thing to
try hmm it's not I mean can you maybe f6
takes g6 but I don't think he promotes
there easily now he's trying he's trying
this I wants to hoard this upon down
okay this is something else no he will
probably I want it
I'm also having I have the the wrong the
wrong bishop that is a problem it's a
dark squared a a one is a dark square
and they've got the light squared Bishop
which is a bit of a shame no beef beef
voice before it's coming
unfortunately just a draw nothing to do
before no it's drawing check
before we can just take even there it's
a draw it's probably the fair result of
the whole thing check stalemate yeah
that was a very equal ish game couldn't
do much our heads entertained sleight
hopes in the end game but in history
just a drop and check here it says here
it's candidly equal and now after that
advance maybe but I think he played it
probably well to hold the drawer this is
this no I have six James takes King
takes King c3 hey ok computer is giving
minus one it's just a draw it's really
just a job there's nothing to do here he
will play before and just block block on
the dark squares there is nothing going
on this this yeah the trade is also draw
it ok the computer wants to go Bishop g6
and things that have that before it's
just drawing there's absolutely no way
forward and something like this here
white is just just shuffling the king is
sorry the king is staying on c3 and
there's no way forward for black and
yeah the in the opening here he played a
very say Jerry quickly ok but it really
is so Chan and so on solid good
everything but reasonably boring but
what can you do you need 728 I think
this is all quite quite logical and now
to prepare six
check yeah it's just very Jewish I think
not much not much to try I guess I was
briefly thinking this is an interesting
move suggested by the engine the ideas
to maybe go for a key in porn ending but
he I also think it should be a draw yeah
okay let's get into game it's probably
more interesting than trying to press
water on a stone in this game thanks for
watching